well multiple sources now reporting that
the government is going to announce
plans to prorogue Parliament next week
returning on October the 14th which of
course would appear to mean that
parliamentary maneuvers to stop a No
Deal brexit would at least be
temporarily curtailed well let's get
more on that from our political
correspondent Lois good or I should say
we will have an interview in the next
hour with the prime minister conducted
by our political correspondent Amara
cone so Lois what do we know
well rumors really swirling all night
Adam that there will be a progression of
pollen the queen is in Balmoral of
course wouldn't be typical for her to be
requested for this in this way but I
understand that at several privy
councillors either are on their way to
see the Queen or already there
presumably led by the Lord President of
the Council Jacob Riis MOG to ask for a
disapprobation of parliament in Council
to use the official term this mean
Parliament wouldn't even come back next
week no no mana standing his opponent
would return over the next couple of
weeks as planned but would be probed on
September the 9th until we think October
the 14th
so therefore the opportunity for any
shenanigans to try and curtail a No Deal
bricks it a little bit more
circumscribed of course we would have
the normal conference recess anyway so
Parliament would be a way for those two
or three weeks of course this also
really does beg the question of exactly
how Parliament will respond to this lots
of MPs will not be content with the idea
of any parliamentary time being curtail
given there was so little time before
October 31st
even to get a deal through potentially
which is still the government's policy
and since there was a suggestion that a
lot of MPs have gone public saying they
don't think there should be any recess
at all over the party conference season
normally two or three week recess and a
suggestion that the government actually
wouldn't be able to get that voted
through by MPs which it would need to do
prorogation does that need to be voted
through by oh well this is a it doesn't
necessarily need to be there's a bit of
dispute about this I'm gonna try to get
the Bach this morning some experts say
that a prorogation if it isn't just a
typical progression which normally would
happen just for norm
for Queen speak as expected wouldn't
necessarily need one but some say that a
statutory instrument might be necessary
to be voted upon by MPs also of course
MPs might try and find a way over the
coming weeks to say we don't want to be
per owed we don't want to be broke we
don't even want to have the conference
today well potentially of course it
would all require I mean of course what
they will be able to do quite easy I
think is pass emotion of course
government the government and tourism
A's government has made it clear in a
past couple of months that sometimes
Parliament passes emotion they're happy
to ignore it lots of talk about trying
to compel them in other ways
legalistically that would be very
difficult to achieve in just a couple of
weeks I think the interesting thing for
this is does it change the calculus of
MPs decisions yesterday the pro remain
MPs to try and focus on legislative ways
to try and stop a no deal bricks it
because of course that was difficult
enough anyway if time is gonna be even
more so subscribe it will be more
difficult to me then have to do it in
the next two weeks so it will really put
the onus on those MPs to decide what
they're going to do will Jeremy Corbyn
for example now turn around and say
having been so emollient yesterday
saying well it's perfectly fine we'll
focus on the lizard solution and say
well now that's rather more difficult
and the idea of a motion of no
confidence comes back into play again of
course is well of course if there's
gonna be a Queen's speech there will be
a vote on part in Parliament on that
Queen speech in October and of course if
a government loses a Queen's speech that
is now under the fixed term Parliament's
Act one of the only remaining ways that
the government can lose confidence but
as you say if they're going for a
Queen's speech and a new session that
presumably means that the rumours about
calling an immediate general election
are off the agenda well presumably so
although of course they must have
countenanced into their thinking that it
is possible that Parliament's response
to this if they're unable to stop
approbation is to have that motion of
no-confidence and their position which
looked a lot firmer over the last couple
of days might be a little bit shaky err
again you have to conclude that it's a
high-risk strategy this is a high-risk
strategy so you cannot try and think
what is Downing streets aiming this my
belief is if you look exactly what
they've done is to say this is a Downing
Street which is not afraid of this all
going it's a little bit awry and ending
up in general election territory one way
or the other because they have
dramatically increased the odds of that
happening almost by accident rather than
while is necessarily
within their control well we're hoping
here for the horse's mouth or rather the
Prime Minister's mouth
in the next hour when that interview is
available to us but for now Louis thank
you very much indeed
developing story here very much at
Westminster this morning